Louis Reddick here on the program how
are you Louis absolutely okay and I
appreciate you are providing the inside
in our Honda inside a report here on
this program when you heard Gettleman
say that at the combine what did you
think well I guess maybe compared to
what happened yesterday I was I I didn't
see this happen I really didn't see this
kind of thing happening and I don't know
what kind of interference maybe he was
trying to run at that time if he was
trying to drive up Odell's price because
ultimately he knew he was gonna trade
him and didn't want people to think he
was on the block I don't know really
what his tactics were but it sounded
believable at the time even when our own
gesina anderson was reporting that
people were still calling what was the
thing that i kept saying was this you
can easily squash this kind of thing by
just not picking up the phone but the
fact they were picking up the phone
led you to believe that it had legs and
out and I was shocked I was shocked the
owners you really aren't in the business
riches you know of paying somebody 21
million dollars in cash we're not even
let's not talk about accounting
mechanisms like cap space and all that
cash and then letting the guy walk and I
know from interviewing there and talking
to them mr. Mehra wanted Odell to
workout in New York that's why he signed
him to that contract last year he wanted
him to work out because he knows how
special the kid is he known and we all
can see it it's easy to see how special
he is so for this to actually happen
some things had to go terribly wrong as
far as the relationships in that
building with the people who he's
working with
or something in order for you then to
turn around
months later weeks later after Dave
makes that statement and trade them for
a mid-rare a mid-level one a late three
that basically a four-engine broke
peppers that is not the kind of return
you get on a guy who you just gave 21
million dollars in cash and let him walk
up it doesn't make sense and I was
shocked I was flat-out shocked it
doesn't make sense because all I'm
hearing Louis is that you know that he
is a handful that is his personality is
so dynamic that sometimes
the always being on kind of maybe rubbed
people the wrong way but it I mean you
work with people like that I mean
everybody listening to this conversation
watching right now could probably point
out somebody in their workplace just
like that but yeah I mean this is the
National Football League
shouldn't it be incumbent upon the
coaches or or ownership to figure out
how to make that work
that's the again we're I don't know
exactly what was going on there but all
I'm hearing is that and the fact that
they think that they're better without
him because the way that they played
offensively with him out of the lineup
towards the end of the season gives them
an idea that they might be better off
without him Louis yeah and that all the
start there there's no way you're better
off without Oh Dell Beckham
there's this there's no way and then
circling back to what you're saying
about aren't you paid and this is kind
of your job to make those kinds of
things work especially a guy with this
profile of course it is if I think if I
took anything away from my time in
Philadelphia with Andy Reid that he used
to constantly say this is a business of
relationships and you find a way to
generally manage these kinds of things
even when they're not ideal even when
they may be a little bit uncomfortable
you find a common ground because we're
in the business of stacking up w's not
else we're in the business of winning
games and Odell's the kind of guy who
helps you win games and he helped the
Giants win games and I understand
look there's no we can all see him if
you don't know the kid that he's he's
his own man and he has a unique way of
going about things but when you hear
some of his teammates talk just on the
on the surface you know even if you
don't know his teammates you hear
something people talk about how
passionate he is about the game how
serious he is about trying to be the
best ever play it how hard he works in
practice no I've never heard anybody say
and maybe sometimes you know some guys
aren't going to come out and say this
anyway but I've never heard anybody say
yeah you know what I don't like playing
with him he is a pain and you know what
he is someone that kind of takes away
from my game and my focus and my
preparations I've never heard that I've
never heard that and I know how
important it was to mr. Mehra for this
to work out because I'll just tell you
this one of the first questions he asked
me when I interviewed with him was what
do you think of Odell and how would you
how would you manage this what would be
your what would be your you know what
would be your tactic how would you
manage this relationship because he knew
he used the word special he used that
word so for this not to work out I guess
you didn't manage the situation and
maybe it was just one of those where you
know sometimes in this business as you
know it gets personal you're dealing
with human beings and sometimes it gets
personal and sometimes you just either
can't figure out a way or you don't want
to figure out a way to try and get along
with someone who's just maybe not do
doesn't do things the way you want them
done and that's unfortunate because what
they're lost maybe it is a game for them
as far as culture is concerned and I'm a
big believer in that too I've said that
even about the Antonio Brown situation
which is much different than this one in
Pittsburgh but sometimes you know
culture is something you it's not
tangible you can't really measure it but
it's real you know it's real and you
know good environments lead to lead to
success as well but I have a hard time
believing that this team's going to be
better off and I think down the stretch
there you know as far as them having
more production without him in the
lineup I would look at the small sample
size man and this football team is going
to be different again this year since
and what you know the great Bill
Belichick says this all the time you you
can talk about carrying momentum from
one year to the next and hang your hat
on things you did in the past that stuff
doesn't mean jack it doesn't carry over
one year to the next it's a whole
different football team a whole
different schedule a whole different set
of circumstances that you're going to be
dealing with in 2019 but confirmation
bias is one of those things that people
always engage in in the NFL they will
point to things in order to justify the
decisions that they're trying to make
and trying to sell them to sell it to of
theirs and it sounds like maybe that's
what they're doing a little bit and
we'll see it's gonna play itself out on
the field I just personally look I said
it's bright from the get-go I'm shocked
and stunned that it happened Luis
Riddick of ESPN here in the Honda
inside a report okay now that we know
levy on Belle's location and we know the
contract that the Jets and he agreed to
that will be official with the new
league year his 2018 sit out gambit do
you think it paid off for levy on bail
Louis Riddick
now I don't cuz Lebanon was after
something that was going to set the bar
and set a precedent for guys who were to
follow him who he thought who were had
that unique skill set like him he was
trying to be a trailblazer
I mean meaning don't value me like a
traditional running back value guys who
have the skill set that I have as
weapons as unique weapons and therefore
we need to be paid differently
our ceiling our financial ceiling needs
to be different than your typical
running back and he didn't do that he
didn't accomplish that now look I can't
really call it an L when you get thirty
five million guys he's guaranteed okay
you know I mean relatively speaking I
think he's gonna be alright he's right
to make his mortgage payment this month
right but he was after something unique
rich you know that and he was very open
and upfront about that but there were
things stacked against him that I think
maybe he just didn't he didn't really
factor in enough like what his age his
age his injury history his history of
not making good decisions maybe off the
field that would jeopardize his
eligibility those are the kind of things
that look in contract negotiations those
are kind of things that GM's use against
you they do and on top of that he's
playing a position that has a short
shelf life and GM's have had a lot of
success obtaining value and performance
at that position through the draft those
are that's a lot of stuff to push
against in order to try and do something
that no one else has done as far as
redefining that position so he made the
bet he took the bet he lost generally
speaking in terms of what he wanted to
office ultimately accomplished but
thirty five million is a lot of money a
lot of money and so maybe when it all
comes down to it interestingly enough
Antonio Browns method of leaving his
team was more effective
potentially and how do you think the
brown acquisition by the Raiders after
what did happen or may not have happened
but we assume happened in week 17 with
him and Ben and the Steelers
how will the fact that Antonio
essentially Instagram lived--and tweeted
along with that his way out of
Pittsburgh will manifest itself for
other wide receivers in future years
Louis do you think this is a one-off or
what yeah I definitely think it's a
one-off I would caution you guys against
trying to do that he got lucky in that
there was a team and a coach in
particular who really really admired his
work ethic his production on the field
in the past and what he projects to be
his production on the field in the
future and you can't take anything away
from Antonio in that way and he's also
this he's a unique unique talent he's
done things in this league that no one
else has done so for the top 2% 1% of
players maybe you can take that risk and
maybe you can go ahead and Instagram
your way off of the team and onto
another one and kind of you know kind of
game the system so to speak and get what
you want and maybe more guys will try it
I would just say a lot more people are
gonna fall flat not get what they want
then are gonna get what they want and I
don't think this is gonna set a
precedent because you know how you know
how to lead get that you know how you
know general managers and people get in
terms of their group thing people will
start pushing back against that and they
will start using the distraction excuse
the bad apple the excuse whatever they
want to use in order to make sure that
guys don't think that they can just
start doing that so I think that the
unique situation I will say that I think
Antonio had some points as far as what
he was upset about what I had wanted to
go about it that way no but in the end
look he got what he wanted but I don't
think this is gonna this is going to
start a tidal wave of people going hey
you know what I'm just gonna sit out I'm
gonna make crazy statements on Instagram
I'm just gonna you know I'm gonna do
features heat less than writing and put
all my business out there in the street
and I'm just gonna do I don't think
that's gonna happen I don't think that's
gonna happen all right some quick
hitters for you here
Louis Riddick in the Honda inside a
report Wow
we were having this conversation Earl
Thomas and Mark Ingram signed with the
Baltimore Ravens what are your thoughts
on that and and do you think that shifts
in any way shape or form their ability
to repeat in the division with everybody
assuming and I started the show saying
this is Cleveland's division to lose now
what do you have so I love the Earl
Thomas signing I loved him between him
and Tyrann Mathieu a little bit
different players but to just dynamic
dynamic guys who play a position that I
think people don't give enough credit
for in terms of how important it is to
have guys who play those positions on
your football team clam at high levels
and Earl's just the difference maker
he's one of the greatest racers of this
league of all time he can erase mistakes
for everyone else because of his
instincts of speed his competitiveness
start I love designing and I love Mark
Ingram III I really hoped and thought
that they would keep those two together
meeting mark and alvin kamara down in
New Orleans
I like the signing for Baltimore I don't
you know I like the signing for
Baltimore in terms of how they want to
play I don't know if I necessarily like
the signing for mark because I'll tell
you this until the marg act it really
proves that he can keep people from
putting 15 guys in the box and daring
him to throw it's gonna be tough
sledding for running backs
tough tough sledding the game is going
to be as Lucinda and the scenes in the
spacing isn't going to be as open for
him in Baltimore as it was in New
Orleans because the quarterback hasn't
proven himself yet if he can prove
themselves then they'll benefit Marvel
will see Baltimore has a lot to prove
okay a lot of good players especially on
the defensive side of the ball so
another quick hitter for you here Tyler
Murray did not get measured we're
talking to you before he throws at his
pro day is he still in your mind the
number one overall pick in this draft as
it comes up shortly Louis yeah I think
he will I think he will be because of
who's picking number one overall unless
they get out of there unless Arizona
gets out of there it is he's the number
one quarterback my top ranked
quarterback no he's not I would take
Dewayne Haskins all things being equal
but I think he will go number one
overall as long as I rizona sits there
and some team doesn't decide to offer up
the you know Mike Ditka style trade and
say we'll give you our
kold-draft you know for the next couple
of years if we can come up there and
take number one overall I think he's
gonna go there yeah but Arizona's brass
owner coach general manager and they're
not at the Oklahoma protei rebuild
steels for me Louis what does that mean
if we we don't really have anything to
gain by going there if we're gonna pick
a number one overall but we'll have
plenty of time and plenty of opportunity
to meet with him individually one-on-one
we don't need to show everybody you know
just because we're not there doesn't
mean we're not interested I mean that
doesn't really mean anything quite
honestly rich okay it doesn't mean
anything did you hear anything different
than what Charley casually reported on
on NFL Network about his work habits
study habits is interviewing at the
combine did you hear anything different
yeah I've heard things that were just
the opposite number 180 the opposite
direction and you know that's how that's
how this time of year goes and I think
sometimes especially on the negative on
the downside you have to be very careful
with believing what teams tell you
because everybody has an agenda
sometimes that agenda it's not very good
it's a little bit disingenuous and quite
honestly it's a little bit dishes and
unfair I don't know people you shouldn't
be saying those kinds of things about
these kids coming out like that that can
seriously alter you know the direction
of their of their drafting
I I don't like that kind of thing at all
and I definitely don't like when people
then will put it out there and repeat it
as if it's the gospel especially if you
weren't there on the doubt so I I don't
I don't like that kind of thing I have
heard very very positive things about
Kyler and I think ultimately it's not
gonna affect him I think he is gonna go
number one overall two last ones for you
Lewis Riddick and in wouldn't with the
NBA free agency were you know we've seen
certainly last year last couple years
some changes and it didn't change that
the the Warriors were gonna win it right
I mean so anything that's happened in
the last 24 48 hours you got levy on
bail going to the Jets you've got Odell
Beckham going into the AFC for Cleveland
you've got a Antonio Brown staying in
the AFC to the Raiders obviously Earl
Thomas coming into the AFC with Mark
Ingram to the Ravens has anything
your estimation in the last 48 hours
when it becomes official new league gear
change the fact that the Patriots are
the champions of the AFC and the NFL
Louis yeah yeah until proven otherwise
look the Patriots just they operated on
the different levels they they just do
and we we all know why but of all the
things that have happened transaction
wise in the AFC Cleveland as long as
Freddie kitchens and his coaching staff
can manage it all and now develop a plan
to utilize it and develop it Cleveland
is back Cleveland is for real and that
is not that is not desire believe they
have gotten weapons that's you you
better strap up for and you better have
a plan to deal with because they've got
a good job of stockpiling talent we know
there's a difference between acquiring
talent and building teams it's Freddie's
job to build the team now but that teams
for real it's exciting at the time to be
involved with Cleveland Brown football
right now as it has been since maybe I
left there that's right don't sleep in
the fact they got Sheldon Richardson and
Olivier Vernon as well asking a poll
question out the door asking the pub I
know how are you hunt I mean come on now
they got they got players as young
players all right with us real quick
whose move will have the biggest impact
Odell levy on Antonio Brown Nick Foles
that's right another AFC NFC person into
the oh man you know what I'll pay this
can I change it a little bit like this
and say this what's the one's gonna be
the most scrutinized and which one's
gonna be under like the white hot light
okay week it's gonna be Nick bull Nick
is kind of carrying with him the same
responsibilities that Kirk Cousins is
carried with him to Minnesota last year
they're saying that in order to pay paid
Nick what they paid him and given what
his team was just a year ago as far as
being a couple plays away from being AFC
representative in Super Bowl that he can
be that difference that's what they're
saying now they have the more work to do
that's the one I'm most interested to
watch I'm a big fan of Nick's and he is
all about relationships and all about
and all about play calling it all about
rhythm the next year we're gonna see
they made a big bet on him a big bet
that's the one I'm watching the club
well I'm a big fan of yours which is why
I allowed you to change the poll
question but do me a favor and ask
answer it as asked which one do you
think biggest impact oh man I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say Odell I'm gonna say Oh
Delbert it's amazing isn't it it's
Sunday that's what I'm saying has Giants
fans
irate right now he's gonna blow up I
guarantee I bet you he just and I think
blow up in a good way that's right
that's right they've got kick
they've got kicking that's there as well
hey Loic louis i really enjoy watching
you on ESPN when I watch you you're one
of the folks they sit there and go you
know what I would love to have worked
with him when I was there so I thank you
thanks Louis look forward to seeing you
more on ESPN that's Louis Riddick @l
Riddick ESPN I follow him on Twitter you
should as well the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience